dude did Russell Brand not do a real
solid test on this weekend because he's
gonna dominate The Comedy conversation
yeah and then Russell Brand came out and
he was like you know what the British
have done enough to Indians over the
years I think that he deserves his
reparations and he slid in and he just
took over the news son do you think that
he's been serving out
um Frappuccinos over the last don't
laugh at that sounds like a delicious we
can't say that word
[Laughter]
do you think that he's been serving up
ratatouilles over these years because we
can't say the word because the word the
word is triggering the words it's also
going to get us demonetized that's what
we really care about so so but what do
you think his scenario has been he might
have I don't know we'll have to see what
the court says and see if they confirm
he's been giving out raffle pies I don't
know
if he's been serving a warm apple pies
to the women of London I don't know okay
can we go over the stories
okay can we just what exactly are the
four women have a huge Russell Brand
um uh giving them these Michael
rappaports and no
well because
I knew it was true
okay that's why I'm gonna make the
conversation alive yeah it would have
made it a little awkward I'm trying to
talk about the metaphysical Universe you
know because in that universe
no okay let's break this down because we
should not be having uh you know these
kind of funny conversations right now no
of course serious issue let's just have
just to chill the hell out okay okay
um
do you have a little drink does anybody
have any scrapples
[Laughter]
yo just a little
snaps
yeah what's your favorite flavor of it
it's funny because uh do you want a
drink is how most of these cases started
but but here's the crazy thing yeah
silver
not from when these stories are coming
out right oh really I don't know I
thought these are all back in the day
when he was a wild boy you didn't read
the article
I don't mind you not reading but I do
mind you trying to correct someone who
read it
excuses
70 of them were about it yeah there's
about 30 of them there are some pretty
short lemonade
a lot of sweet tea uh the thing that
bothers me about the emotional Truth uh
line is that
comedy is actually that like if you look
at old like borsche belt stuff like the
one-liners like take my wife please yeah
the emotional truth is ah my wife can be
kind of frustrating so I'm going to
write a joke that is uh and by the way I
finally understood that Joe Broussard
explain it to us it was take my wife for
example
that's the sentence that you would
normally say you know women are amazing
take my wife for example but the girls
are amazing take my wife please please
yeah so uh but the emotional truth is my
wife is frustrating so let me write a
joke about giving her to another man or
something the emotional truth is there
that's what comedy is emotional truth
and then you write a sarcastic or a
misdirection or a fable a lie punchline
that satisfies that emotional truth so I
don't even like him co-opting this
emotional truth thing because if you
look at so many of the Great comedians
the emotional truth is there like you
look at Eddie Murphy doing the uh half
yeah the half joke oh yeah uh you know
in raw yeah you're talking about like a
woman getting half like the frustration
that comes out look at uh but Bernie Mac
talking about his three kids yeah and
what he would do to the three kids he's
talking about hitting him that's the
emotional truth I don't think he's
beating up these little [__] kids I
mean black family fair enough but he's
not scared of them but let's say let's
say he is let's say for example he is
not doing anything but he recognizes the
emotional truth is it's funny to say
that he I beat him to the white meat
he's not gonna beat you until that yeah
but it's funnier yeah funnier to say it
so I don't like that even being pulled
in there because that's pure Santa pure
stand up is not lying about
victimization yes and then not
satisfying it with a joke like that yeah
I don't I don't like that one other
thing with Hassan I just feel like here
looks great and he's just a handsome so
handsome in a hairline is fantastic
she was racist bro she was [__]
racist Hassan and don't you ever forget
it yeah okay it really [__] bothers
me yeah dude that thing really [__]
bothers me because he became uh like so
ingratiated with the Hollywood Machine I
also think people are taking it harder
on him you know what I mean like if some
if this happens you don't like Hollywood
you're using him yeah like as the latest
uh uh I think he can be seen as a agent
of like liberal media and as a result
there's all these people on the right
that are ready to like go at him no
matter what I don't even think they
really care about I bet you most of them
didn't even see the spot he's just a
tool yeah he's just a tool for them to
hammer away at liberal media he also
used them to get you know I mean like he
was in he used it to get where he was
and placated them and played to them
well that is another thing either to
them at all times I think you should
always be
wary of and this is on the right or the
left anybody that 100 chose the company
line or the party line oh yeah or and a
lot of times it's not even party because
I think because Hassan would push back
against Democrats obviously push back
against Republicans but if the if your
philosophy is liberal or republican only
100 you should always be a little bit
skeptical of what's going on here
because oftentimes that's more of a
costume that you're wearing for
financial gain and uh both sides this
happens on both sides and the people who
are going to still go to his shows are
going to be okay with the fact that it
was lies because it serves the truth
that they want to hear exactly exactly
so yeah that's something like you said
always be wary of uh I'm sure you've
done this a thousand times but there
were certain people on the right wing
that wanted to interview me and bring
back who came out and I was like no you
got your [__] mind you think I'm
doing that because I'm not gonna be your
puppet yeah you're not going to do this
to me where you want an agenda and then
you wrote me into it and then I'm a part
of it no I'm going to be an independent
human being to think straight yeah and I
think if you do that that you're gonna
get [__] whenever by the other side
whenever the truth comes up okay look at
that Integrity just
I think this a lot of times happens and
the problem is that he did create some
really beautiful art like I remember
watching the first special and it was
beautiful it was it was really great
like the way that they did it and it was
it was just really good and um
but I think I think the problem is is
like you know we talked about this
before it's like when you're focused on
Art you'll try to stay true and
authentic to that art yeah and I think
when people get caught up in success or
the addiction for fame
um you do anything you can to feed that
the coolest thing you did after the
infamous is six months off of stage six
months because I wanted it to be pure I
wanted to find the next and what you're
doing now it's so different and so cool
yeah that's not happening if you're
chasing something besides the art yeah
100 and uh listen we've got some some
huge advantages we have a very
successful podcast that is gonna pay the
bills so we have the ability where we
can take time off and find out
the next thing that we're passionate
about how we want our art to be
reflected like what we really want to
write about and that takes [__] time
if you just go right back into it you're
just gonna rewrite the same version of
the last thing you did and
so I think we should take advantage not
everybody has that there are some people
they just need to keep pounding the road
because they got [__] kids they got
mortgages they gotta keep doing it so um
but this is I think this is a good
example of wow that works so well how
can we beat that what if I don't have a
story that's as good as that let's say
the first one was real what if you don't
have another story that's as good as
that yeah well that's what people want
they have to deliver that we've [__]
on her on this pod and all that but I'll
say this I watch Hannah Gatsby's both
are specials the second one she said
something was very self-aware she was
like dude if I had known trauma was
going to make me so much money I
wouldn't have used it all up in the
first thing and that immediately makes
you trust her where you're like oh she
at least acknowledges and now she's then
she just does like the second one is
like a comedy special it's hers but it's
not like some tromedy thing it is just
like we're trying to be funny whatever
it's personal but like every I can
respect trying to do it differently than
exactly and if you found out that Hannah
didn't tell the truth about that about
the things that happened she had so much
success with obviously there would
there'd be like this icky feeling yeah
and I also think putting the purse not
like if she put the person up that did
it and was like here's a picture and
it's blurred out and then people were
able to dox him and his life got ruined
and then came out none of it was true
yeah you would look at her and be like
that's [__] crazy yeah that's crazy
yeah so I think it's okay to have this
reaction and I think Hassan has to take
this and this is the bed you made but I
don't think that his career is over
should he quit stand up forever no I
think you should just go back to doing
stand-up like do stand up where you can
you know more take these liberties with
jokes
you know what I mean like actually
reverse what you're doing you know I
think he's going like here's the tough
emotional thing right here and then
there's no joke at the end of it like
just use these tough emotional things as
the joke you know what I mean like your
daughter finding this powder in it
immediately and you know you're finding
a powder in an envelope right and you
having to like remove your daughter so
you could snort it you know what I mean
like whatever that's the joke it's like
she's already into this America's
corrupting them blah blah not oh my God
these Anthrax the world is so racist and
look what's happening to me yeah you
know his ex special could be fire if he
goes full eye if he just opens up like
the way Louie opened up with like so how
was your year yeah yeah if he's able
just to confront it and be really honest
about what happened yeah I think he
could just bounce back yeah I mean that
is the beauty of uh of stand-up and art
it's like you're if you're able to
articulate what you are doing how you
did it in an entertaining a fun way
people will listen yeah people listen
Russell on the other hand might have a
little bit of a heart so what do we
think with the Russell thing because
obviously when we when we ask them to
come on the Pod you know we'd seen this
guy uh come to America and like there
was this massive Splash when he came
you're so [__] charismatic
um really funny Charming in person very
charismatic of course engaging and then
these stories come out so there's four
stories there's four different girls
that are claiming uh different uh
I don't know versions of
sexual assaults and rape
um one girl it's a age thing I think
they started dating when she was 16. no
there's an assault with that because the
age thing and she was 16. yeah and then
Russell takes interest they go on dates
whatever parents weren't into it she
feels like there was grooming involved
but the age of consent in the UK is 16.
so that in and of itself isn't illegal
it's just icky to use your earlier yeah
but then she says there was also uh
assault within the relationship I think
he like uh made her give him head while
she was sleeping or something like that
something like that and like she's like
punching him again the story says she's
punching him to get her off he won't do
what he finally does right and then he
says according allegedly I just want to
see your mascara run away a bit which
the verbiage is also sounds like the way
an English dude would say it so you're
like well that sounds like familiar
warding that's rough also he wears
mascara too so maybe that's something
that he's more familiar with yeah he
just has a greater understanding mascara
run away watch your face bro exactly
yeah I mean
um now is it now her parents didn't
approve of the relationship is Day races
I think they are racist I think they
could I think they showed up at the door
yeah and then her parents were like I
don't think it's a good fish yeah she
was dressed as Osama Bin Laden again no
way of when he went on a date with her
that's why they said we don't want you
marrying a Saudi Pakistani
because he's brown yeah
the thing about it that's obviously
tricky is and he brought up something
that I thought was quite interesting
it's when he was working at channel four
I guess which is like a British Channel
this is a British channel news channels
or whatever
um I think Channel 4 was one of the uh
organizations behind this Expose and
it's like so when I was working for you
you didn't care to do the background
check to find out if there was any
legitimacy to this you were arguably uh
protecting me from some of these
allegations and now that I'm not working
for you now that I'm going against the
mainstream media now that I'm pushing
back against the narratives that you
push all of a sudden you're willing to
come forward with this article which is
I understand also these four women
only came out when approached by the
journalist so they weren't coming out on
their own accord no one of them tried
well she went to the clinic and got the
anti-rape care or the rape kid or
whatever she got the rape kit but then
she chose not to press charges and
pursue it yeah so it is a tricky
situation and women don't pursue these
things for many different reasons okay
there's embarrassment there's fear this
is like a famous 100 so and he already
did something to me that's like 100
gonna terrify me forever 100 but
unfortunately this also does create room
for skepticism when the journalist is
tracking down the girls and going hey
didn't he do something to you these
other girls said he did it hey didn't he
do some hey didn't he do something and
all of a sudden you're trying you you
have a specific
motive here the journalist
it appears doesn't want to find out that
he's innocent yeah her article is he's a
predator and she's gonna keep asking
people until she finds out that he's a
predator yeah now we would hope that
they have the journalistic Integrity if
she didn't find out that they were that
she would just go okay we're not gonna
We're Not Gonna post anything I'm not
gonna write this article but again you
don't know and there is that wiggle room
right there
so this is this is It's Tricky man it's
really [__] tricky do you think his
audience will care assuming that the
Chargers go through and he's not
convicted in a court of law because
they're not able to prove it
hypothetically I think it stops him from
doing anything in like the industry
for a long time unless he is uh
exonerated I think it hasn't been given
up on the industry though yeah he has he
has it it might make things tricky like
having a big time promoter for his tour
or putting out a special on a on a
Netflix or an Amazon or something like
that it might make those things tricky
but he can continue to exist I think
online and build his following multiple
allegations is always a lot yeah yeah
that's a lot yeah now when he was on on
the show you kind of mentioned that he
wasn't very Indian and he was using
Indian ideas yeah this is the thing that
uh just one of them yeah do you feel
like he's proving his Indians is one of
them do you believe it I don't know if I
believe him but I like him thank you
can he do the Hindu stuff
no that's not Hindu dude that's not
Hindu it is a little Indian
all right let's [__] let's not
conflate these two things
that's fair that's fair
about Catholics on the other hand they
all know nothing about rapists yeah no
of course not that's your faith dude
yeah dude he's not American you guys
don't know what's going on
come on man anyway the uh so what are we
thinking here what happens to Russell
hopefully it's not true yes like in all
these cases hopefully women weren't uh
are not victimized yes but uh what's
crazy is I think he gets bigger
oh if if he's oh if he's accused
and then it turns out that it was
[__] well it doesn't even have to
turn out it was [__] like a rape
conviction is apparently I didn't even
realize until recently really hard it's
even hard to get it to trial so until
that happens it's just gonna be this is
[__] nothing is happening at the
trial it just yeah gets bigger he has a
voice to fight it yes he does he's a
platform he is everything yeah and a
rabid following to so that that is the
truth that is the truth though if if he
if if it look if it turns out he is
innocent he is without a doubt bigger
and not only is he without got bigger
he's now a Target he must be doing
something crazy he must be doing
something wild he must be really yeah
we're filing up the elites yes exactly
and he can lean into that 100 percent
um
and there seems to be enough wiggle room
the fact that none of these women came
forward the most damning one obviously
is the girl who went and got the kit
yeah done and she got a rape kit done
and uh
I would assume that there would be DNA
from both parties on that um
no yeah
she would still have to prove that it
was not consensual and this is going to
be a he said she said situation this is
probably why it's important that there
are other women involved but at the same
time you don't know if there's enough
evidence especially this many years
later to prove that um
this is a tricky one yeah yeah even talk
about this [__] is tricky like yeah you
want to make jokes but it's you know